POWER.
JOINING ME NOW REPUBLICAN
SENATOR FROM ARKANSAS TOM
COTTON.
SENATOR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING WITH ME.
I APPRECIATE IT AS YOU COULD
TELL, I'M A LITTLE CHARGED UP
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE PRETTY OBVIOUS
IN THE MIDST OF OUR WORLD.
YOU CLEARLY NOW HAVE A
REPUTATION FOR SEEING THINGS
EARLY FOR BEING WILLING TO STAND
UP TO THEM.
CAN YOU START BY EXPLAINING WHEN
WE HEAR NOW THE ARGUMENTS ABOUT
WE SAW THE HACKS OF THE OIL
PIPELINE OF THE MEAT SUPPLIER,
THE WARNINGS ABOUT THE POWER
GRID.
HOW IS CONGRESS BECAUSE WE DON'T
SEE IT HOW IS IT THAT THEY SPEND
THEIR TIME DEMONIZING AMERICANS
AS THE ENEMY WHEN THESE THINGS
ARE HAPPENING IN REALTIME AND A
AFFECTING OUR LIVES TODAY?
>> WELL, IT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS REALIZED THE
CONDITIONS THEY ARE CREATING IN
THE COUNTRY AND THE RESULTS OF
THEIR POLICIES ARE NOT GOING TO
HELP THEM AT THE BALLOT BOX NEXT
YEAR.
YOU KNOW, WE JUST SPENT A WEEK
BACK IN OUR HOME STATES OUT OF
SESSION IN THE CONGRESS.
AND I DIDN'T HEAR ONCE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE PAST OR ABOUT NANCY
PELOSI'S OBSESSION WITH THIS
COMMISSION OR ANYTHING ELSE.
I HEARD LOTS OF COMMENTS ABOUT
HOW OUR BORDER IS STILL WIDE
OPEN AND KAMALA HARRIS HASN'T
EVEN VISITED THE BORDER OR HOW
EVERYTHING FROM GAS TO FOOD TO
LUMBER IS SKYROCKETING IN PRICE.
WE HAVE A CRIME WAVE ACROSS OUR
NATION AND CITIES.
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD ABOUT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT NORMAL
AMERICANS, NORMAL ARKANSANS CARE
ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT DECIDES ELECTIONS
THAT THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THAT
THEIR POLICIES IN NO SMALL PART
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR HIGHER CRIME
AND HIGHER PRICES AND THE BORDER
CRISIS.
SO THEY WANT TO FOCUS ON THE
PAST AND WHAT MATTERS TO THEM
PERSONALLY AS OPPOSED TO WHAT
MATTERS TO VOTERS.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO PAY A
REAL PRIZE TO THAT.
>> Tammy: THERE SEEMS TO BE.
A RECENT ELECTION THAT THE
BORDER AROUND TEXAS WHERE
REPUBLICAN WON THAT THEY SEEM TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
MINORITIES ARE GOING TO BE
VOTING.
AT LEAST IT'S HEARTENING, I
THINK YOU WOULD AGREE WITH ME,
THAT WITH ALL OF THE MEDIA
PERPETUATING THE DEMOCRAT LINE,
YOUR CONSTITUENTS, AMERICANS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, STILL GET
WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
THEY ARE NOT BEING DISTRACTED BY
THAT.
DO YOU FIND THAT SURPRISING
CONSIDERING ITS LEGACY MEDIA AND
BIG TECH COMING AT THEM WITH THE
SAME MESSAGES?
>> I DON'T FIND IT SURPRISING
THOUGH BECAUSE SOME ARE A
CANSIANS LEARN NOT TO TRUST
EVERYTHING THEY READEN IN THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND CNN.
AND THE LAB LEAK THEORY OF THE
ORIGIN OF THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THAT I WAS POINTING OUT AT THE
BEGINNING OF LAST YEAR AND THE
VERY FIRST DAYS OF THIS PANDEMIC
WHEN MOST OF WASHINGTON WAS
OBSESSED WITH THE IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL, YOU KNOW, THIS VIRUS
DIDN'T START UP IN SOME REMOTE
MOUNTAIN VILLAGE NEXT TO A CAVE
FULL OF BATS.
IT HAPPENED IN A CITY THAT'S
LARGER THAN NEW YORK RIGHT DOWN
THE STREET FROM THE LAB WHERE
THEY RESEARCH THESE CORONAVIRUS.
SURELY ANYONE WITH AN OUNCE OF
COMMON SENSE WOULD SAY WELL,
GOSH, MAYBE WE SHOULD TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THEY SAW THE
CORONAVIRUS AS A WAY TO ATTACK
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HOPEFULLY
UNDERMINE HIS RE-ELECTION.
DISMISS WHAT I WAS SAYING AS A
FRINGE CONSPIRACY THEORIES AS
SOMETHING THAT HAD BEEN DEBUNKED
WHEN OBVIOUSLY IT HADN'T BEEN.
EVERY BIT OF EVIDENCE WE HAD
POINTED TOWARD THAT LAB.
THAT'S STILL THE CASE TO THIS
DAY.
NOW THAT DONALD TRUMP IS NO
LONGER IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THOUGH, THEY ARE WILLING TO LOOK
AT THE FACTS AS THE FACTS AND
NOT EXACTLY ADMIT THEY MADE A
MISTAKE BUT ACKNOWLEDGE THE
REALITY OF IT.
AND WHEN NORMAL ARE A CAN SANS
SEE THAT KIND OF DUPLICITY FROM
THE MEDIA, THEN THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY CAN'T TAKE EVERYTHING
THE MEDIA REPORTS AT FACE VALUE.
>> Tammy: AND THAT'S WHAT'S KEY.
IT'S FASCINATING TO ME BECAUSE
YOU ARE DEALING WITH THE
PANDEMIC.
THE POTENTIAL AS WE HAVE H
MILLIONS DEAD.
AND THAT DIDN'T EVEN STOP THE
DEMOCRATS FROM USING THAT TO
COMPOUND THE FEAR POINTING AT
DONALD TRUMP THE ONE PERSON WHO
HAS DELIVERED THE ELEMENT NOW
THAT IT'S FREEING US FROM
HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE THE VACCINE.
HE CONTINUED TO BE BERATED AND
VILIFIED.
YOU HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE I
ALWAYS WONDERED ABOUT SOMEONE
LIKE YOURSELF THAT YOU GO TO
WORK WITH THESE PEOPLE.
YOU DEAL WITH THEM.
IT'S GOT TO BE REMARKABLE.
YOU WORRY ABOUT THE KINDS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING TO RUN
FOR OFFICE.
HOW, WITH WHAT HAVE YOU
EXPERIENCED, I KNOW YOU ARE
PUNITIVE COUNTRY THANK GOODNESS.
HOW IS IT THAT YOU PUT UP WITH
THIS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH LIFE AND
DEATH HERE?
>> WELL, I LOVE OUR COUNTRY AND
I LOVE SERVING OUR COUNTRY I DO
IT IN UNIFORM AND I'M VERY HAPPY
TO BE DOING IT AGAIN IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE ON THE
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
ARKANSAS.
I UNDERSTAND SLINGS AND ARROWS
COME WITH THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU STAND UP AND UNPOPULAR
TRUTHS AT LEAST TRUTHS UNPOPULAR
WITH THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATIC
PARTY SO THEY CAN USE ALL THE
NAMES AND SLANDERS THEY WANT.
BUT THAT'S NOT GOING TO STOP ME
FROM DOING WHAT'S RIGHT
REPRESENTING THE COMMON SENSE
VIEWS OF ARKANSANS AND IMPROVE
LIVES FOR AMERICANS.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED
MORE OF THIS CONGRESS.
>> Tammy: YOUR POSITION AS A
SINGLE SENATOR FOR A STATE HAS
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
IMPACT WHETHER YOU DO THINGS FOR
THE RIGHT REASONS.
WHEN I WAS ON THE LEFT, THE WORK
WAS DESIGNED TO TRY TO PUSH GOOD
PEOPLE AWAY TO GET PEOPLE TO NOT
WANT TO DO CERTAIN THINGS AND
THAT, I'M HAPPY TO SAY,
CONTINUES TO FAIL BECAUSE OF
SENATORS AND PATRIOTS LIKE YOU,
SIR.
THANK YOU